thanks for stopping over at lumni Acres
a guide to Modern homesteading
self-sufficiency and freedom in today's
video we're going to talk about the
seven Essentials you need for starting
and raising happy healthy chicks the
number one thing you're going to need
for keeping your spouse happy when
raising your chicks in your basement or
your house is the mother hen you heard
me right this is the mother hen it's
just a cardboard box but it's important
so when you're raising chicks ducks or
turkeys in your house at night they
chirp and they make a lot of noise when
you want to go to bed so you take your
mother hen you put it over the chicks
and they're quiet as can be they'll
sleep through the night nice and sound
they don't make a peep until morning
comes and you take the box off and they
and they see it's morning time you might
be thinking it's kind of cruel to put a
cardboard box over your chicks but in
nature what do they do the mother hen
sits on the chick so this is more of a
comfort to them and quiets them and
makes them FAL happier so trust me it's
kind of like swaddling a baby you wrap a
baby up nice and tight and it likes it
it's like being in the womb so the
mother hen cardboard box is the same
thing to the baby chicks don't forget
it then you're going to need some kind
of waterer you got a big Bell one like
this or you got a little one a lot of
these depend on how many chicks you're
doing if you're only doing five to 15
that's big enough if you're doing 25
this is big enough to start out but once
they get bigger they're going to be
drinking more water so you got to get a
bigger gallon water we put a little bit
of apple cider vinegar in our chicken
water to start and it just helps build
up their immunity then you're also going
to need feed we use organic chick
stutter non-medicated that's totally up
to you something you need to do research
on for yourself if you want to do
organic nonorganic non GMO and if you
want medicated non-medicated we don't
use medicated we've never had an issue
not using medicated but I know some
people feel one way or another so that's
fine that's your call it's your family
it's your chickens it's their your eggs
it's their eggs you're going to be
eating and it's the meat that you'll be
eating so it's totally your decision
then you're going to want some different
feeders this one again is a little bit
bigger so if you have 25 more chicks you
don't want the bigger one you can just
have the little on fill up the Mason jar
you can buy the plastic cup that goes on
it you fill it up with feed we just use
a Mason JY you fill it up with feed
screw it on and then dump it
over they all work really good the next
thing you're going to need is you're
going to need a heat Source when we
raised our chickens last year we didn't
need a a heat light we just kept the
chicken pan right near the woods stove
and that kept them more than warm enough
throughout the whole growing season till
they were able to go outside we never
once Ed the heat light if you are going
to use a heat light make sure you got
the right the proper light keep the cage
on so it doesn't get too close and start
a fire I'll I'll give you an up close
but we use a ceramic heat bulb when we
need it or you can get an infrared one I
don't like they say not to use the white
cuz it blinds the chicks the red ones I
personally don't like looking at a red
light it drives me bonkers
so do I want my chicks to have to look
at a red light all the time I wouldn't
want it so I'm not going to make my
chicks do it I got the ceramic heat Bal
another preference it's totally up to
you that's why I don't use the red one
I'm going to leave a link in the
description below for Amazon that shows
all the items that we have here and you
can purchase them through the link and
the best part is when you buy all the
stuff from Amazon they'll throw in the
mother hand for free
woohoo sorry for all the noise in the
background it's 50° out today all the
snow is melting and that noise you're
hearing is the Brook running but it's
not quite Springtime here yet but it's
getting close to the time where we're
going to start thinking about getting
some more chicks here so that's what
made me think about making the video
today so another thing you're going to
need is you're going to need a pen to
raise them in and depending on how many
chicks you plan on Staring at once
depends on how big of a pen you need to
raise them we got this water tro that we
use so we're doing like 25 birds or more
once they get big enough we'll stick
them in
here most of the time we just use pine
shavings for beded you can use newspaper
that works really good shredded paper
really whatever you have if you can get
shredded paper easy or if you got a
shredder use your own paper save some
money and then compost it afterwards
we're only raising a few chicks at a
time or a couple of
ducks I just grabbed this old dog pannel
we have
set it
up and use this then you got the
problem then you have the problem it's
opened on the
sides then if you leave the sides open
the chicks just push all their bedding
out so one little trick I
do I just RI the cardboard the length I
need it
and zip tie
it up on three sides I leave the front
open thanks guys for watching I hope you
like the video if you did give it a
thumbs up don't forget to subscribe and
this is the way that we raise our happy
healthy chicks here and grow them into
nice healthy hens and get some great
fresh organic eggs this right here to me
is freedom we don't have to go to the
grocery store and depend on everybody
else to get this nice delicious food for
us we'll see you right back here next
time at lumni Acres a guide modern
homesteading self-sufficiency and
freedom
[Music]